I like Timothy chalamet he's a sweet boy
I'm sure can we get rid of this cancer
in every film like he's Willy Wonka now
what he's Willy Wonka I would just
saying that show he's a child but he's
not let if you're gonna put him in this
JK Rowling has to write it sure I want
if you're gonna do this you need JK
Rowling yeah because I want a Turf movie
I want a movie where he's like the world
is wondrous and magical but it's not
that magical and it's not that wondrous
there are some things that are just
biological truths there's an infinite
number of jelly beans yeah but only two
gender do you understand that I get
wacky and crazy on the subject of
chocolate but when it comes to gender
it's very important that we just say
that there are men and there are women
chocolates can make people fly we can
defy the laws of gravity but we will not
defy the laws of God